all right this should be fun and this is
a character from nobody we haven't seen
throughout the tournament day so far but
he's been known to use this character at
a very high level and for the longest
time throughout season three and maybe
even some of uh early in 2019 was using
steve as his tournament character
yeah so no uh
again has to be very careful because he
can gain those counter
back one counter hit back ones
he's very oppressive with this steve
but this is again we're talking about
you're so good with this
what's he doing he caught him looking
and he hit him with the hop kick a very
emphatic hop kick i mean bro he's like
one of the only hop kicks that does a
backflip when he does it
that's true
i mean one of the best looking and the
best functioning hop kicks out there in
the game
let me see how nobody's going to deal
with that early seconds and he is
already in that life lead but you know
what yeah again always a constant threat
checking with those mids forcing him to
duck and
rest assured he has that df2 locked and
loaded
oh here we go
can the comeback happen again yeah has
some rage
oh
he was ready nice able to capitalize
tied up on rounds now
wow did you see that i didn't allow him
to continue that string nice punish from
the hop kick on no beside
4-1 he was waiting for that magic
forward to hit and now again reaping
those rewards gets the side wall
gets the the shaheen steel pedal or the
sand pedal
whoa
what a hop kick again right now two
rounds to one looking to extend the lead
here
you know the momentum that he had in
that opening match when he fought
against nobody
let's see what he does here and yeah
slide
yeah it's so scary to give again that
momentum and
so far so good he has been running away
with the early seconds of this round
nobody has the work cut out for him
trying to find those openings big back
one finds its mark
and also the wall
[Music]
see what he does here they're about even
on life
but the positioning is is everything
having the ability to get a launch get a
big counter hit and have the wall
can mean the mix-up between life and
death
true
he did
trying to go for a big read there early
like final seconds already side is on
nobi
now we see down three gets
nullified again does have rage he's
trying to fish for it the down three
misses and now nobi final seconds again
not able to get enough and now we're
gonna see a final round fight oh yeah
here we go very very important let's see
what happens here
it did
luckily for nobi yeah that could have
paid dividends and now we see again in
the back foot here
one more sequence from nobody could
steal the deal
there we go
he was able to close it out there with
that clutch up forward one and nobody
drawing first blood here showing that
the steve fox picks that definitely paid
off in this particular matchup so good
stuff
yeah and this is gonna be a long journey
for nobody right he's gonna have to pace
himself because he need he wants the the
toc uh japan masters glory he's gonna
have to reset this and this is a good
first step one match at a time uh one
round at a time uh a famous man once
said it doesn't matter if you win by a
mile or an inch a win is a win
that is true that is true it's all about
family as well
there we go all about family but either
way i think
looking at this uh i i do think shaheen
is going to have a harder time going up
against this tree and i wouldn't be
surprised especially because he has some
room to kind of mess around here i
wouldn't be surprised if we saw switch
i don't think it's going to be
i don't think it's going to be
um
fakamram and i don't think it'll be
lydia i think it might be leroy i think
it might be leroy
we were talking about how uh devastating
leroy has been and still is you know
even though there were some changes to
some of his moves he's still like from a
god he's a demigod but no still sticking
with the shaheen now again as you
mentioned he does have some room to
breathe here he knows that nobody is at
the losers maybe he wants he he has like
a game plan here going to violet systems
this is his stage so he's probably going
to change things up in terms of pacing
just to stay away from those big counter
hits that nobody has been able to land
oh yeah down two
crunches ankles nice gets the knock down
again already with a nice light fleet
here oh he catches him with that did he
really mean to do that dang
it worked out in the end i guess all
part of the plan for him
and now let's see how uh nobody'll get
himself out of this situation oh my god
the hopkick
here we go and that's going to be the
first round again drawing first blood
here round two i mean it was quite
convincing too i mean the the the way
the last round ended in the in the
previous matchup it showed the dominance
of the patience of uh of nobe here
and one of the things that nobody's
really good at is pressuring with that
duck cancel you know he'll go for the
down forward one two one or he'll go for
the down forward two into into the lost
ending one and kind of fish a
confirmation out
and luckily steve's noggin was right
there for him to be able to land that oh
my god it's the punish nobody know
like in big trouble so let's see how
again we'll try to close this out oh
rage gets nullified
one two close that one out no be in
trouble
yeah it's looking really really good for
getting right now again
getting acclimating himself to the
match-up and against uh against nobi's
style with steve it's starting to show
and work out for him
oh look he was able to step the wall
standing two after that
brilliant sequence there but nobody okay
now
able to get himself outside that wall
trying to push for the other side of
this stage
again though very much in this match
trying to fish for his openings being
very conservative here because he
doesn't have that much life to spare
we see that yeah nobody's trying to
trying to cover his options not not
being too open for any of gen's uh
options here
and the dash blocking just him getting
in his face and starting to block is
such a hard thing to really able to do
especially against steve
um
oh my god
counter hit one one guaranteed follow-up
and again three rounds straight good
stuff
mark what happened i just blinked and i
thought they were spacing each other out
i thought i was gonna like take another
10 more seconds but man you cannot sleep
on again especially uh yeah when he
finds his opening he really rips into it
and he's just he's so sharp he's second
to none when it comes to those type of
type of like explosive gameplays
yeah
man all right looking into this so we're
tied up here now one match a piece
i'm trying to think here like is there a
counter to this is this something that
we're gonna see to the very end where
it's gonna go down between these two
characters and and it'll go either way
whether it's a reset or not or do you
think there's gonna be another level of
strategy that's gonna be coming at least
from from nobody's side because right
now it's on him whether or not he wants
to change
um i think he he still has one more room
to adjust but
um
like you said he's gonna well this match
is very important right if he's gonna go
over a character switch he has to do it
now because it's gonna be harder if he
loses this match and then he has to
switch and the last one so he cannot
afford to lose with that new character
so i think he's gonna have to like the
character he picks now he's gonna have
to commit with it throughout so
we'll find out i do think that again
after that solid match um yeah
nobody's gonna have to be able to uh
adjust
really like a lot uh coming into this
one
all right guys here we go tied up one a
piece here
this is grand finals
again right now with the advantage of
course he is on the winner's side
nice you should get the wall here let's
see what he does
okay got the blue stuff and get
guaranteed now the 4-1 lands oh my god
yes these scrambles that are getting so
much uh well against reaping so much of
the reward from so
still sustains the momentum from violet
systems
yeah he's making it count
nice and again with the pressure but a
big counter in fact one
that's something that we really haven't
seen too much from nobi in the match up
and look at that all that life
eradicated from his life bar
very offensively sound start from novi
and wow picks him up let's go round
three yeah able to get that conversion
that was big taking that round
all right here we go
yeah he's challenging more of those back
ones and those uh those low options okay
able to pick him up finds the wall too
yeah really made it count there great
stuff there with extended duck one the
fall up here again look at that using
the down forward one two one
in conjunction with the flicker stance
to really keep his opponent out of there
oh oh
did he press caught him with the wrong
he did oh my god he did it beat this
move timing-wise oh that was huge
whoa able to escape the throat oh my god
went for the dempsey but oh it's all
good on the side of noby
my god the dempsey roll the cobra weave
able to sneak out that round using the
rage drive that we don't really see from
uh from steve
yeah
and you saw how you again tried to
nullify that but yeah it was checkmate
there for nobi no it's raining a
dragon's nest oh hop kicks him his way
out of it okay oh yeah slippery hop
kicks let's see what he does he's back
to the wall he's gonna have to be
careful gets the knock down
now it's on again dan does have the
lively here is he to tie it up on rounds
one more hit could do it
wow
final round mark man here we go yeah
huge round this is a very important one
gets the counter yet
oh and he's going to get the wall he
dropped it
wow
it's another counter there's been so
much counter hits in this round alone
now they're really leaving it on the
line another one follow that up one more
spends the drive nobi oh eat the down
four and just like that again up two to
one
not only that he needs one more match
and he will win the tournament here for
the tekken online challenge japan master
event and right now his level of
dominance i i would not put it against
him to go ahead and do that in this next
match nobody has to do something
it's uh it's dire straits at this point
yeah so far like we've witnessed the the
journey again right and so far he's been
unmatched dare i say it's second to none
with how well he's performing and we did
see some uh well we saw nobody like no
like turn on the offense a little more
but we saw how much counter hits he uh
that again was able to get out of those
situations so
it's quite tough to be in in noby's
shoes now because ken i think is firing
on all cylinders it's it's look like it
looks like he has all the momentum let
alone with shaheen a character that he
has only brought out now against nobi
definitely
of course getting ready for what could
potentially be the final match of the
tournament but i hope you guys have been
enjoying the action so far this is the
tekken online challenge and we are about
to get ready
for our next match
oh he's going with the dragon
the commitment again okay
because of the count because nobody if
he loses one more match he is out of the
tournament he is now stuck with dragon
up for the remainder of the set he has
to win two matches
two matches with dragon up tie things up
you know just to breathe a sigh of
relief and reset it but yeah he's gonna
go with old main here
so let's see how much damage he can do
again oh gets tackled oh goes breaks his
leg
oh yeah
wow what a df2 there by again
all right this is a real test
not only for for both of these players
but for dragging off ken dragonov hang
with how the momentum has been for again
so far right now it's not looking good
mm-hmm
yeah
again just dragging nobody to tough uh
unfamiliar territory in rough waters now
oh man slide atlanta all going up again
side though
look at the life lead
what's he gonna do
down twos
forcing some scrambles coming out again
but you look he's he's not faltering
he's just standing still he's waiting
for his openings to happen less than 30
seconds left on the clock and there's
still joking and driving for some
positioning here look at that
they're still baiting some activity like
shadow boxing waiting for something goes
for the running too nice escape on the
side of again
again knows he has the likely doesn't
want to risk anything
sometimes it's about the art of fighting
without fighting and again these guys
waiting time is a wasting they both have
rage
oh in a trade
tournament
how crazy was that now let's see if genn
can make it seal the deal with no round
brown here but look at that the df2
lands on no be side he's fighting back
moves away
ooh gets another launch okay nobody with
a surge of energy here with a surge of
of momentum let's see if he can sustain
it
how is he going to do it here
right now again looking really good here
making good use of that down three
oh my gosh and the punch
again slowly picking apart uh nobi here
with these lows now mids uh oh down two
able to track him down
nobody does have some rage he does have
some tools to work with here but again
just needs that one big swing can he get
it though less than 30 seconds left on
the clock eddie confirms again ladies
and gentlemen is your tekken online 2021
japan masters champion
what is the secret to his power i have
no idea he's so un he seems unstoppable
he's like a world beater
that's the power of youth and
determination man that's always how it
goes and you know nobody has been a long
time player i mean even again you know
again as young as he is he's been
playing the game for a long time but i
got to give it up for both of these
players congratulations to nobee for
getting second place but the man of the
hour again
really showcasing how
how solid it is and of course the
opinion of a lot of players the best
player in japan right now
maybe maybe yeah i think more than just
in japan